lili angie is one of the most well-known
faces in martial arts movies but you
probably know him better as Jet Li from
martial arts movies in the 80s and 90s
up to modern-day franchises like The
Expendables Lee has been an action star
for as long as many moviegoers can
remember but fans were sent into a
frenzy after a 2018 photo of the actor
appearing aged beyond his years went
viral the snapshot was almost
unrecognizable as the great martial arts
star born in 1963 the martial artist
would have just turned 55 at the time
the buzz worthy picture was posted but
many thought he appeared to be 20 or 30
years older people made their concerns
known all around the world but is there
really any reason to worry
here are the real reasons why Jet Li
looks completely different kung fu cults
master Jet Li is an actor with a rare
resume born in Beijing Li grew up
practicing martial arts on a nationally
competitive level transitioning to a
movie career in his late teens
since then he's appeared in both Chinese
movies and Hollywood productions but he
slowed down his Hollywood output around
2010 Li's partial withdrawal from the
spotlight had to do with the diagnosis
of hyperthyroidism when he announced he
was suffering from the illness Lee said
that the condition left him feeling
uncertain as to whether or not he could
continue working as an actor in martial
arts movies despite this setback Lee
seemed content about the situation
saying in 2013 I'm in pain but I'm not
suffering I'm happy
concerns gone viral
please diagnosis again became cause for
concern in May 2018 when a photo taken
of him at a Tibet temple went viral the
photo which showed the five foot six
star hunched over with short gray hair
and glasses made him look remarkably
older than his age Li's relative absence
from American movie screens in recent
years
coupled with the implied notion that he
was gravely ill helped the image to
circulate rapidly suddenly a man who had
convincingly defended entire Nations on
the screen looked like the sort of
person you would help cross the street
fortunately things aren't nearly as bad
as they might look while an overactive
thyroid can cause drastic changes in
one's weight and resting heart rate it's
a treatable condition while the disease
has required lead to change up his
lifestyle
it's reportedly never threatened his
life as his manager told The Washington
Post he has hyperthyroidism that he's
been dealing with for almost ten years
it's nothing life-threatening and he's
dealing with it he's all well and good a
painful career Lee has a lot more going
on with his body than an overactive
thyroid and he's been building up damage
in plain sight for our entertainment his
whole life
as a result of his many injuries Lee has
said he suffers from problems in his
legs and spine with the issues keeping
him from being able to stand up straight
for too long the damage is part of a
history in martial arts that goes back
decades earning him a torn knee that
required surgery to fix at the age of 18
and a major back injury at the age of 23
according to the South China Morning
Post Lee has said he was told by doctors
in 2013 that he would end up in a
wheelchair if he continued to work in
martial arts films which helps to
account for his slowed output in the
genre since then who could blame him the
movies he's already done get to live
forever but Lee himself only gets one
chance from a bad angle
Lee's public relations people were quick
to pounce on the emerging viral story
with his manager telling USA Today that
his client was quote completely fine
though Lee's manager assured readers
that Lee appreciated the outpouring of
concern he also made it clear that the
rumors of Lee's declining health were
greatly exaggerated not to mention a
snap judgment based on one photo of
questionable composition as Lee's
manager put it
it's one picture and people are making
these interpretations if you took a
picture of me at the wrong angle and the
wrong time of day I could look frail as
well as the photo gained traction with
news outlets around the world social
media commentators pointed out that much
of Lee's appearance could come down to
issues of lighting posture another
external factor is not indicative of
failing help the bad photo Theory has
merit in December 2017 Lee shared a
photo on Instagram wishing his fans a
Happy New Year
while his appearance in the video is
similar to his look in the viral photo
he appears considerably healthier older
but not in trouble dear friends this is
Jack I wish you happy holidays in the
great year 2018 Romeo is fine
while Lee does look different now it
doesn't appear to be because his health
is declining nor are things as bad as
one photo makes it look Lee is still
working as a filmmaker though he's kept
most of his work aside from the
expendable series in China that may
change soon as the actor is reportedly
in talks to star in the live-action
version of Disney's Mulan set for
release in 2020 Lee may be getting older
but rumors of his condition have been
greatly exaggerated
just because he's cooled it with the
high kicks doesn't mean he's done
kicking around thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]